malheureusement, toutes les bonnes fêtes doivent prendre
fin
mec tu es bouleversé bouleversé je t'ai donné
cent millions de dollars tu as 15
millions de plus tu as accepté de ne pas dépasser
parce que tu as dit que je ne pouvais pas réaliser à
moins que nous ne soyons d'accord c'est comme quand une fille
demande si vous voulez frapper sa soeur chaude
bien sûr vous dites non aucun de vous
ne croit vraiment que vous en avez besoin mais qu'est
-ce qu'il fait ici prêt pour les ennuis ces
filles ici folles nous savons que nous
revenons par la mémoire n'avait pas l'habitude d'être
vraiment  gros
ce film est énorme s'il échoue
tu t'enflammes plus vite que
Hindenburg pourquoi as-tu arrêté de prendre les
médicaments contre la colère je ne pensais pas qu'ils
fonctionnaient je suis d'accord pour continuer si ça
ne marche pas on peut toujours reculer
dans le Queens je ne veux pas y aller les gars s'il vous plait
mon frère j'aime trop le temps ici
prenez moi environ je dure trente secondes
tu me laisses t'emmener à un rendez vous durent
60 secondes j'aime le temps je mourais trois
secondes
qu'est ce que c'est  Bari, quel genre de studio tu
cours ici, il ne le fait pas  comme le
drame veut le couper ils essaient de
couper mon frère j'ai tué quelqu'un même
si tu étais aussi mauvais que le drame craint probablement